German
[Music]
this is the journey to birth
herein lies the promise of our lives
the hope of all our futures
the source of so many human dreams
[Music]
thank you
for most parents the Journey's End birth
proclaims the arrival of one more
healthy happy beautiful child into our
world
for most parents pregnancy is a season
of success
for most parents it is a reaffirmation
of their own good health their own wise
decisions
however some 6.8 percent of babies born
in the United States are of low birth
weight
and by being under five and a half
pounds they are at increased risk
in fact low birth weight is the greatest
single killer of infants it is at the
root of many defects occurring in later
life
it cost Americans one and a half billion
dollars of medical treatment each year
isn't it ironic that in a nation
possessing the most advanced Medical
Care and Technology a nation obsessed
with the notion of extending human life
that we rank a mere 18th in the world in
being able to prevent infant mortality
but don't be intimidated by statistics
there is much an expected mother can do
to improve her chances of a healthy
child
meet Kathy shell mother of Two And soon
to have her third
her views are those held by many
pregnant women
I know pregnant women really should be
concerned about their diet and I know we
all try and we all talk about how good
we're going to be but there are days
when you just want to go to peppermint
Park and eat 10 hot fudge sundaes and
before this pregnancy is over I am going
to do that
let's see what your weight is this week
it's getting unfair
well the concept of weight gain and
pregnancy has really changed over the
past 10 to 15 years the the Mandate used
to be the the lower the weight gain the
better targeting it around 14 to 15
pounds for an entire pregnancy Dr Harold
Fox
today we're encouraging approximately 25
pound weight gains which are associated
with very good fetal growth and
generally very good nutrition for the
mother as well as for the fetus
this 25 pound Target fortified by a diet
rich in calcium and iron offers mothers
like Kathy hope that their fetuses will
flourish
even now at the beginning of pregnancy
at the very outset of our journey diet
is important
today six weeks on the way towards birth
we can sense the embryo's fragility and
dependence
at this stage the embryo is the size of
a mere adult thumbnail
its future shape is only just being
defined
moving up its back we can perceive the
developing spinal cord
[Music]
arms and legs are also being formed
inside the eye there is the first
glimmer of its lens
and beyond that a suggestion of an ear
Kathy knows that eating well by itself
is no guarantee against birth defects
many still defy science
but in numerous cases genetic and
chromosomal birth defects can be ruled
out as early as eight weeks after
conception
the risk of Sunburst defects can even be
predicted before pregnancy by genetic
counseling
since there was no reason for concern
with Kathy's pregnancy she was told its
continuing success depended mostly on
her with the support of her husband
one precaution Kathy had taken early in
her pregnancy was examination by
ultrasound
a procedure that actually visualizes the
developing fetus through a sensor placed
on the abdomen there's the heart right
in this area
right there
what we're trying to do is to look at
each chamber and make sure that they're
of equal size are relatively equal size
and that's what we're seeing here on the
screen for instance you can see the four
chamber view a couple of ventricles in
the in the picture right now
this looks like a a great heart
such Windows into the womb are enabling
not only mothers to perceive the state
of their own pregnancy but scientists to
comprehend the very intricacies of fetal
development
when the fetus is eight weeks old we now
know just how vulnerable it is this is
the time when mere buds are growing into
recognizable arms and hands and
fingernails when tiny stumps are
evolving into delicate legs
this is the time when development is at
its most precarious a time when a
physician's advice regarding the use of
any medication including common
over-the-counter drugs should especially
be sought
[Music]
thanks to these windows into the womb a
mother can now have a clearer idea of
how to conduct her own life during
pregnancy
I am not a smoker and I've never been a
smoker but I do have several friends who
have you know smoke regularly and also
have continued to smoke during their
pregnancy they however made a very
serious effort to cut down to five to
ten cigarettes a day and I personally
see no reason why that would be a
problem to the fetus
Science Now believes that on this point
Kathy is absolutely mistaken any
cigarette smoking affects the fetus
consider for instance it's heartbeat
under normal circumstances the heart of
the developing fetus might beat 140
times a minute
shortly after the smoke penetrates the
mother's lungs There is almost always a
dramatic change
clearly the mother's smoking is reducing
the supply of oxygen to the fetus
thus forcing its heart to beat faster
but smoking has other more Insidious
dangers as Dr Xena stain knows from
continuing research I think there are
some things about cigarette smoking
which we now know in controversibly from
many many studies one thing for instance
a woman is more likely to have a
miscarriage if she's a cigarette smoker
and the miscarriage is more likely to
have affected what it looks like to have
been an otherwise normal pregnancy so in
a way it's as if it was a waste of a
pregnancy due to the cigarette smoking
uh
second thing we know and we know this
even more
um firmly than the first is that the
baby will be smaller in birth weight
than it otherwise would be
a half a pound in birth weight may not
seem very important to many women and
it's true that if the baby is about
seven pounds then between six and a half
and seven and seven and a half there's
not that much to it but as you go down
in the birth weight for instance a baby
of five pounds four and a half pounds is
a small baby five pounds of small four
and a half pounds is smaller I think uh
if women knew
embryo and fetus that's growing there is
actually being impeded in its growth by
the cigarettes they smoke she would
never do this in the postnatal period
when she sees her infant she would give
optimal environments to the baby but she
does it during pregnancy she dumps down
the rate of growth and I think that's
wrong
since Cassie is a non-smoker we can
assume that at 10 weeks of age her
fetus's growth had not been inhibited by
the use of tobacco
by now while the fetus is a mere two
inches long it can move actively its
liver is its most visible internal organ
as always the fetus is both the
beneficiary as well as a potential
victim of its mother's diet
[Music]
I'm now on my third pregnancy and I'm
much more overall I'm just much more
relaxed about food in general
and drinking I tried I mean I'm keeping
it moderate I'm not a heavy drinker I
truly deep down inside do not feel
that an occasional drink is detrimental
to the baby I I I think if it was my
body would be telling me something I'd
trust my body all along to tell me when
just what foods to eat and I pick up on
those feelings and I go with it and when
I have a couple glasses of wine you know
my body is not giving me any ill effects
and
I see no no danger
science does not agree with Kathy about
moderate drinking for reasons that Dr
Kenneth Jones has observed over many
years we now know that alcohol can lead
to serious problems in the unborn baby
at one end of the spectrum we have
babies with a condition that is known as
the fetal alcohol syndrome the fetal
alcohol syndrome is a very specific
pattern of malformation which is seen in
The Offspring of chronically alcoholic
women who continue to drink heavily
during their pregnancy and we now know
that 44 percent of babies born to women
who are chronic alcoholics have this
disorder known as the fetal alcohol
syndrome
eight years ago Roger was born to such a
mother one who drank excessively during
pregnancy
the result permanent brain damage
his condition fetal alcohol syndrome is
accompanied by a characteristic facial
distortion
he has a defective heart
his hand and hip joints will never be
properly formed
for Roger there is no cure
but what can Roger's extreme condition
tell the pregnant mother who is only a
moderate drinker
although at the present time we clearly
know less about moderate drinking than
we know about chronic maternal
alcoholism there are certain facts that
we do know
in a study that has recently been
completed we have discovered that 11 of
babies born to women who drink between
two and four glasses of wine a night or
a day during the first trimester of
their pregnancy have evidence of the
prenatal effect of alcohol it is my
feeling that the best chance that the
fetus has is for the mother not to drink
at all during her pregnancy
there are very few things that we really
can prevent in this life this is one
thing that we clearly can prevent and I
think we should do everything that we
possibly can to do so
by the end of the first trimester in the
12th week of pregnancy a healthy fetus
is able to perform astonishingly
delicate movements given the most basic
restraint and consideration by its
mother it not only survives it thrives
[Music]
bound together through the umbilical
cord the mother can keep few secrets
from the fetus for it must depend on her
way of life for sustenance
one contemporary development in our way
of life is the dramatic increase in the
use of drugs
I personally do not take drugs before or
during my pregnancies nor do I have
friends that take drugs I think it's a
just a really dumb idea to fool around
with them and you're just taking
a real risk
they chemically alter
the body and I just wouldn't take the
risk of them chemically altering the
fetus just to have a kick I don't think
the kick is worth it
Kathy's feelings about drugs are
absolutely correct but drug use is
becoming a nationwide problem as Dr X
Lina Bean knows firsthand this is a baby
who was born to a mother who was hooked
on TCP since the mother was hooked on
PCP the baby was born addicted to PCP
babies who were born to drug abusing
mothers tend to be very tense when
they're born they tend to be what we
call hyperactive or hyper hypertonic
they tend to be very jittery which means
that they shake a lot they tend to be
very irritable and they do tend to cry a
lot because of the increased type of
activity that they have this often
interferes with them eating sleeping and
they often have have for instance
diarrhea so then basically it interferes
with the kind of things that are
necessary for the baby to do in the
first couple of days of life in order to
thrive while studies of the long-term
effects of drug abuse during pregnancy
are still being conducted did we can now
say with assurance that an infant born
hooked is an infant who is clearly not
given the best start in life
I'm a real believer in exercising
because I've seen it
you know through my own pregnancies that
it really helps with the back aches it
helps with cramps it gives you extra
energy
it's terrific and I think it really
makes a difference whether you feel good
or bad during your pregnancy
for mothers like Kathy who enter
pregnancy in good health continuing the
modest exercise program is recommended
but for those who never strenuously
exercised before pregnancy is not the
time to begin
throughout the mother particularly the
working mother should respond to any
subtle changes in her body possible
signals of premature labor by
immediately contacting her physician
[Music]
had we been able to observe Kathy's
fetus at 18 weeks we would have seen
that it had grown to five and a half
inches in length
by now its mouth and lips were fully
formed and its nose contained remarkable
nasal plugs whose purpose science still
does not fully understand
and while its eyes were closed they were
fully formed
foreign
anatomical systems are now developed
during the next 20 weeks preceding birth
it will change little in shape but its
size will increase nearly four times
[Music]
the womb is filled with amniotic fluid
which the fetus inhales and exhales as
if it were air
[Music]
oh
on the day Kathy's baby was due
she was still waiting
[Music]
38 weeks three days and 17 hours after
her pregnancy began Kathy went into
labor and was taken to the hospital by
her husband
because the fetus had shifted position
during the last few days of her
pregnancy and because her first child
was delivered by cesarean section a
decision was made to perform the same
procedure this time
getting the head out
oh
boy
[Music]
yes hello
hello happy birthday
[Music]
he's getting used to breathing
Blake Butler shell
weight seven pounds nine ounces health
excellent
[Music]
all right today his greatest journey is
at an end
thanks largely to the wise decisions of
his parents that Journey was a stunning
success
I know but I want to look at him
[Music]
I'm your mom you have a brother and his
sister waiting to see you
gonna look like huh
oh he is cute
so nicely proportioned
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]